the U.S is hoping to buy up to a hundred
thousand artillery shells from South
Korea so it can give them to Ukraine the
U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin is in
Seoul for talks some estimates suggest
that Ukraine's armies using the shells
at twice the rate that the U.S and EU
can produce them South Korea has a
policy of not selling weapons to
countries that are at War Rob McBride
has more from Seoul
the global search for 155 millimeter
shells for Ukraine's guns has now turned
to South Korea which doesn't want to
antagonize Russia because of its
influence over North Korea right now
Ukraine is getting through about 90 000
shells per month that's double the rate
at which they're being produced by both
the US and Europe combined the U.S has
reserves here and it's buying more than
100 000 shells from South Korea to
replenish stocks being sent to Ukraine
that way Seoul can help its Western
allies without contributing directly to
the war effort let's bring in Andrey
lenkov who's a professor at cookman
University and director of NK news
that's an online news source focused on
North Korea he's joining us from Seoul
welcome to Al Jazeera sir so uh will the
U.S defense secretary Lloyd Austin get
what he wants
I would say not necessarily a song
because there are serious kind of
arguments for and against making
strategy
first of all generally sells carrying
public is supportive of Ukraine like in
most democratic countries but they still
see Ukrainian War as a distant conflict
where they have no Stakes
and at the same time there are two
reasons not to get in trouble with
Russia first of all Russia is a
significant trade partner for South
Korea and South Korean foreign policy is
highly pragmatical sometimes up to the
point of being cynical they are quite
willing to trade with whoever is going
to pay money and Russia is a significant
trade but but what is more important is
North Korea historical relations between
oscari and Russia well have sometimes
been difficult but very often they were
allies formal or informal even formal
and if South Korea starts sending shells
to kill Russian soldiers in Ukraine one
would not be surprised if Russia starts
selling something to North Korea which
might kill South Koreans right but if
the U.S and the defense secretary gives
assurances to South Korea and
Washington's commitment for example when
it comes to the North Korean nuclear
threat surely that is what South Korea
would be looking for is or not
they already have such assurances even
though there are some people in South
Korea who says that probably assurances
are good but South Korean nuclear
weapons to be developed is better so
they already have it but at any rate
they want to have good relations with
the United States South Korea is very
pro-american country and especially the
current government
so if there is a serious pressure from
the United States maybe just maybe a
South Korean government will basically
do what Americans want it to do it's
possible because once again no matter
how important Russian Market no matter
how much they worry about North Korea
yes right now relation with the United
States come first so if pressure is
really high or rewards are really high
they might make concessions but
something tells me that most likely
South Korean government will find ways
erupt right but behind the scenes behind
the scenes
to what extent do you think that the
Americans are are pressuring South Korea
I don't know I think they are pressing a
bit but I don't expect them to press
hard and this is why I sort of mildly
inclined to believe that so scary and
ammunition will not be sold to be used
in Ukraine I'm not sure of course as I
have said there are arguments was
against this deal and for this deal but
well South Koreans have always been good
in dragging their feet if in order not
to do something they don't really want
to do all right thank you so much Andrew
Lanka for speaking to us from Seoul